previously on hunter x hunter after lots
of trainings and many fights in the
heavens arena go managed to fight hisoka
but still lose the fight while hazaka
compliment him about his progress he
said he still has a lot to learn the
story continues with gon traveling back
home to whale island along with killua
upon arriving he meets mido outside
their house and embraces her she also
breeds killua and then invites the two
inside their house
nito shows go in a small box which his
father gave him and she tells him
everything she knows about jing
she tells him jing was the same age as
gone when he left whale island to become
a hunter 10 years after leaving jin came
back carrying gon and asked his grandma
to take care of him
when mito asked jing about gone's mother
jing replied that they separated
after learning about his dad gohan
starts calling his father by his first
name jing and wants to learn more about
him the next morning gon and killua have
trouble opening the small box from jing
killua suggests using men on the box and
the metal protecting the box falls off
and another is under it
a slot for the hunter license is found
and they are able to open the second one
too
inside the box contains a ring a memory
card and a cassette tape gone decides to
listen to the tape first while playing
the tape jing's voice is heard and he
asks gon if he wants to see him
while playing the cassette tape gone
hears his father's voice for the first
time
jane congratulates gohan on becoming a
hunter and asks him if he wants to see
him giving him two choices if he wants
to see him just continue listening and
if not just press the stop button
gordon listens until james voice says
gohan must want to see him but he
doesn't want to see gon saying he's a
bad person for choosing his own desire
instead of being a parent as gon and
kilua listen to the tape jing is seen
riding on the top of two unknown
creatures he continues to speak telling
gone that he is doing reckless things
and if gon wants to find him he will
make it as difficult as possible
after hearing those words gone was
pumped up and more eager than ever
kiluah is about to turn off the cassette
but gon stops him stating that there is
still more
jing then asks gon if he wants to hear
his mother's voice but gon stops the
cassette quickly and tells killua that
his mom is mido after the two are done
listening to the tape an aura appears
around the tape player nan was used on
the cassette tape making it rewind and
then record even though gone pulls out
the switch of the cassette and kilua
tries to break it and the cassette
continues to move and erases james voice
the two move on to the box again and
look at the memory card kiluad decides
to buy a game console at the online
website toyland so they can use the
memory card after kilua buys the console
they insert the memory card and learn
that a game called greed island is saved
on it they discover the game is
incredibly expensive adding up to more
than five billion
kilual calls his brother maluki to learn
more about the game and maluki has two
leads kilua promises to trade a copied
version of the memory card to maluki for
the information he tells go on a rumor
that a dozen copies of the game will be
distributed at the southern peace
auction gohan and killua bid farewell to
mido and her grandmother and the two
head toward their next destination york
new city
as gon and kalula leave whale island
korepika tries looking for a job before
setting out to avenge his comrades he
approaches the agency but the woman
inside refuses as corepika lacks
something else she uses nen to test if
he can see it but when it's obvious he
can't the agent suggests korapika should
come back once he learns in the forest
someone attacks him and introduces
himself as mizukan
he challenges korapika to a fight but
korapika loses mizukan tells korapika to
come with him as he is willing to be his
teacher after some training of men mizu
contests korapika with water divination
in order to learn which category does
korapika's aura belong
korapika then uses random something
forms inside the glass mizukin confirms
that kora pika is a conjurer he then
rates his ability to learn other nen
types conjurer is one hundred percent
enhancer is sixty percent transmuter is
eighty percent emitter is forty percent
manipulator is sixty percent and
specialist is zero percent
korapika leaves mizukin after learning
men and comes back to the sengi guild to
find a job
the agent finally accepts korapika and
lets him choose which employer he wants
to work for he chooses the one who
collects human trophies he leaves the
agency after his decision and crosses
paths with melody who hears his unstable
heartbeat
in the senji guild melody is seen
talking with the same agent korapika
talked to
melody requests for an employer who has
connections with the york new city's
underground auction on september 1st
meanwhile maluku receives the memory
card from kilua and starts deciphering
the data he also sends the link of the
hunter-only website to killua gon and
kalua are about to arrive at york new
city
after arriving at york new city gon and
killua visit an internet cafe to gather
more information on greed island after
entering the link for the hunter-only
website that maluki had given kiluah the
two successfully accessed the hunter
website cohen swipes his hunter license
and enters his license code to gain
access the website enters a virtual
tavern that gone senses is exuding then
the two decide to talk to the tavern's
bartender to see if they can find any
information on greed island
by depositing a large fee for the
information the two learned that greed
island is a game created by men
practitioners each copy of the game has
men infused within it and in order to
play the game the player must also be a
nen user once a player starts the game
they are pulled into the world of greed
island
players cannot simply leave the game by
cutting the power to the console
if you die within the game you die in
real life in order to participate in the
auction the two decide to raise money by
looking for rare treasures online and
then reselling them although they start
off doing well by the end of the day the
two are unsuccessful in their pursuit of
funds
meanwhile korapika's first mission will
be escorting the boss to a hotel in york
new city dals allen then leads the four
to their boss the group enters an
extremely lavish pink themed room in the
back sits their boss the young woman
nostrade on the outskirts of yorknew
members of the phantom troupe are
beginning to convene the leader sits and
waits for all the members to arrive
before giving out his orders not very
far off corapica and his fellow
bodyguards lead their boss to her hotel
in york new
the car then unknowingly passes by four
members of the troop walking towards
yorknew on the side of the road
the members discuss that this is the
first time they've all been called
together in over three years and that
hisoka is a new member
meanwhile dalzollen phones the real boss
nostrade's father to report the results
of her fortune telling
from the fortunes the two realize that
the underground auction will be too
unsafe for nostrade and decide that she
will be unable to attend
as the day wanes nearly all the members
of the phantom troop have gathered
except hizoka he soon arrives and the
leader gives his orders he states that
they will be taking everything that is
up for auction in the underground
auction and if anyone tries to interfere
they have his permission to kill him
looking off into the sunset corapica is
certain that the phantom troop will make
an appearance at the auction gon and
kalua visit the your new city market
gong decides to buy a new cell phone and
they run into lyorio
as the three reunite the group chats
about men and later tells lyorio about
the game greed island
they gather some information about
increasing their funds and lyorio has an
idea about a certain way called bind the
nostrada bodyguards have been assigned
to their positions regarding the auction
that will be held tonight dazzling gives
further information about where the
auction will take place
leorio gone and kalua invite people off
the street to participate in their event
where people can challenge gone in an
arm wrestling contest and if they win
they can obtain a diamond worth three
million might comes and go and continues
to win when suddenly a girl challenges
him
the match is intense and gone wins but
uses his full strength in order to beat
her who later is seen talking to other
members of the phantom troupe
the auction is about to begin as
corepika and melody stand at their
positions karapika wonders if the troop
will ever show up this catches melody's
attention as she hears the same sound of
rage in his heart the moment she saw
corepika leaving the employment agency
she mentions the scarlet eyes and
corepica finally tells everything about
himself and the scarlet eyes he tells
melody he plans to find all the eyes
taken from his comrades and return them
karapika then asks melody why she took
the same job as him the dark sonata
which is believed to be composed by the
devil itself befalls whoever plays it or
hears it causing disaster upon them
karapika is skeptical so melody shows in
her arm which has been mutated and
shredded
after only hearing the flute version
from a friend for a moment her body
turned into the way korapika sees it now
her friend died completely decimated but
in exchange melody obtained the ability
to hear the sounds of a person's heart
she wants to restore her body find the
complete sonata and destroy it so that
no other person will suffer the same
tragedy meanwhile the underground
auction is about to start
baez evelynkov and tosino have been
deployed into the underground auction
an event where mafia community leaders
from around the world gather to express
their wealth in the form of auction with
all the guests gathered in the auction
room featon and franklin walk onto the
front stage disguised as the hosts upon
welcoming them all the to the event
feyton cuts his speech short and
franklin lets his nen bullets fly
killing nearly everyone in the room
tosino attempts to defend himself in his
comrades with his nen ability but is
unable to block franklin's bullets he
then realizes that the bullets were made
of nen baze and ivlankov quickly flee
out of the room but are met by another
member of the troop shizuku
a conjured vacuum cleaner named blinky
after franklin killed all the people
shizuku uses blinky to suck in all the
bodies and blood from the auction house
leaving no traces behind
karapi got contacts to delzon to report
the current situation at the auction
house including that all the merchandise
to be auctioned has been taken the
entire mafia community then sets out on
a manhunt to capture the thieves
meanwhile the members of the phantom
troop escape by a hot air balloon
hubel informs their leader that the
merchandise was gone before they arrive
at the safe since the mafia had taken
steps before their arrival lumo reasons
that there must be a traitor among them
their leader crawlow however explains
that a traitor would have nothing to
gain from this situation
thus there surely was not one within the
troop they learned that the shadow
beasts an elite group of assassins under
the ten dawns have been called in to
deal with them and that a member of the
shadow beasts was the one responsible
for emptying the safe beforehand
cruella then gives the orders to kill
any mafia member that stands in their
way in order to draw the shadow beasts
out the air balloon is soon spotted by
the mafia and shot down the community as
well as the remaining no straight
bodyguards rush to the area where the
balloon has landed the mafia attempts to
surround the troop who are watching on a
cliff from above
uber decides that he will be the one and
only to take on the mafia and jumps down
ready to put on a show alone
he begins to easily pick off the members
of the mafia with only his brute
strength appearing to be an unstoppable
force even an anti-tank bazooka had
little effect against him korapika and
his comrades who are watching from afar
are stunned by the power that ubel
possesses and are afraid to go after him
while dalzalein says they cannot abandon
their mission melody hears the sound of
another group headed towards them
suddenly a worn-like beast appears from
below the ground and introduces himself
as worm
rabbit dog leech and porcupine also
members of the shadow beasts appear the
shadow beasts confidently say that they
will handle the phantom troop and enter
into the battlefield
the shadow beasts attempt to attack lubo
while the other members of the phantom
troops sit around while playing cards
warm is the first to attack punching ubo
in the face but receives an even greater
punch back in a hurry to get away in a
mobilized ubo worm squirms underground
and attempts to pull ubo under with him
to freed himself from worm's grip ubu
uses his big bang impact blasting a huge
crater into the ground and critically
injuring worm
he then attempts to punch porcupine only
to have porcupine's needling body hairs
stick through his hand
ubro attempts to free himself from
porcupine but is unable to do so
meanwhile rabid dog takes multiple
swipes at uber with his fangs biting off
pieces of uber's flesh and injecting
poison into his bloodstream lubo
eventually collapses from this poison
allowing leech to enter the battle
leech fills ubo's body with spotted
leeches that he has stored within his
body wubo then bites off half leech's
head killing him in a bullet-like
fashion lubo spits a piece of leech's
skull into rabid dog's head killing him
as well to get porcupine off him wubo
screams extremely loudly knocking
porcupine out perhaps killing him
fill the poison and leeches oobo asks
shizuku if she can remove them both
however she can only use blinky to
vacuum non-living things for this reason
she is able to remove the poison but not
the leeches with the shadow beasts down
korapika with his eyes burning scarlet
tries to move in
he is stopped by dal's allen but
somewhat hostilely resists melody stops
the two's feuding by playing a song on
her flute calming everyone surrounding
her
although now appearing calm korapika
tells the group that he still must go
after ubo
using his chain jail korapika pulls ubo
out from the crater and takes off with
the rest of the nostrade family by carr
after capturing ubo korapika along with
his fellow bodyguards are tailed by the
other members of the phantom troupe the
help of machi's nen thread and needle
she attached to ubo
however owl from the shadow beasts
suddenly jumps in front of the car where
the phantom troop members are currently
riding in and entraps them using his fun
fun cloth
all the members are able to escape
except nobody who gets caught due to his
position in the car
then later the other remaining shadow
beasts appear after underestimating the
troop the shadow beasts recklessly
attack them even though all warns them
to take caution for he knows what
they're capable of
all of the shadow beasts are killed by
feigen and shizuku except for owl who
they plan to interrogate to find the
location of the auction house treasures
meanwhile the nostrada family bodyguards
are back at their headquarters
wubo is held captive and is unable to
move due to the poison instilled in his
body and asked them how long he had been
asleep dal zalin makes him realize his
situation and stabs him using his sword
but it is easily broken by uber's body
protected by nen
hugo proposes a deal and if they free
him he will let them live korapika asks
him where the bodies of the mafia
community people went at the auction
since his comrades were part of them
hubo tells him that they killed them all
because they had to owl is tortured by
fighting and gives up easily he then
gives him the treasures hisoka asks
crawlow for permission to go meet
someone dal zalin calls the mafia and
gives them their location to surrender
ubo to them in an abandoned amusement
park hisoka meets with korapika
hisoka tells korapika the things he
knows about the phantom troop and asks
him if he wants to team up if he agrees
he will tell him the abilities of the
seven phantom troop members he knows the
phantom troop led by finks disguised
themselves as the mafia and arrive where
ubo is being held captive they set him
free and kill zalin after ubo is able to
move due to the removal of poison done
by shizuku's vacuum he starts destroying
the place and hunts down korapika who is
not present inside the building his
fellow bodyguards escape because they
heard ubo's scream lubo wants to stay
behind and ask his comrades to tell the
chief that he will hunt corrupt back
down after bashing out the steel dwarf
ring with his head
at the same time hisoka meeting korapika
at a merry-go-round awaits his answer to
join forces before korapika can answer
melody calls to inform him ubo has
escaped
after hanging up korapika asks ahsoka if
he knows anything about the scarlet eyes
hisoka only knows that crolo admires
what he takes and eventually sells it
off he tells korapika he doesn't want to
team up but exchange information as
kurapika wants to kill the phantom troop
and hisoka wants to kill kralow
karapikat doesn't answer walks away and
tells hisoka to meet in the same place
tomorrow back in the hotel room melody
karapika squala basho and linsen sit
around wondering what to do next squala
tells the group nostrade's father is the
one who hired them they all picked
korapika to talk to him however this is
exactly to his plans to become close
with the mafia to dismantle them
karapika tells light that dalzelin is
most likely dead and he's taken
leadership he also tells him about the
phantom troop attacking the auction
light agrees and kurapika leaves in a
random dead person's apartment ubo
drinks beer to get that the leeches out
of his body while xiaomark looks on the
hunter website to find where ubo was
being held captive he finds out the
nostrade family is there at the same
time korapika is looking at the same
information he realizes the phantom
troop can easily find where they are
he orders the others to go to another
room while he'll stay there hubo is
already killing those on the list of
possible places to find the chain user
meanwhile gon killua and lead oreo
discuss their money situation they
continue their armed wrestling scam when
a mafia boss tells them about an
underground fighting ring where they can
make much more money just as gohan is
about to enter a fight it is cancelled
because the mafia wants everyone to look
for the phantom troop members there are
incredibly huge rewards for them dead or
alive they call karapika i tell him
about the bounty on the troop but he
doesn't answer he stands face to face
with ubo
the end of part six if you enjoyed this
video be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell to not miss the next
part